SUSANNA: Authors at Google
today is very pleased
to invite David Mindell.
David Mindell is
the Dibner professor
of the history of engineering
and manufacturing at MIT.
He has 25 years of
experience as an engineer
in the field of undersea
robotic exploration
as a veteran of more than 30
oceanographic expeditions,
and more recently, as an
airplane pilot and engineer
of autonomous aircraft.
He is the award winning
author of "Iron Coffin-- War,
Technology, and Experience
aboard the USS Monitor,"
and "Digital Apollo-- Human
and Machine in Spaceflight."
And his most recent book,
"Our Robots, Ourselves"
was published by Viking on
October 13 of this year.
Please join me in
welcoming David Mindell.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID MINDELL: Thank you Susanna
for that nice introduction.
It's a pleasure to be here.
And I'm going to talk
about my new book,
"Our Robots, Ourselves."
I come to this book sort
of out of the experience
of my previous book, which
was called "Digital Apollo."
And "Digital Apollo"
was about the computers
and the software that were used
inside both the command module
and the lunar module for
the Apollo lunar landings
in the '60s, how
they were designed,
how they were engineered.
It was really the first
embedded computer.
It was certainly
the first computer
that software became
central to human life
and was life critical software,
and one of the first real time
control computers, and the first
digital fly by wire system.
And you can see in this image
over on the right, which
is the cover image-- it was made
actually by John Knoll who you
may know from Industrial Light
& Magic-- and a little bit more
clearly presented here.
The book focuses on this kind of
climactic moment in the Apollo
11 lunar landing where
the mythology went,
Armstrong reaches
up and turns off
the computer the last minute
and lands the spacecraft by hand
to avoid this crater
that you can see there
out the window, West crater.
And the book sort of takes
that moment as a starting point
for why would he turn
off the computer,
and why was that important?
And now it turns out that he
didn't turn off the computer.
He turned it from a fairly
highly automated targeting
mode that kind of allowed
him a kind of cursor
control around the moon
to a still fairly highly
semi-automated
mode, attitude hold
in his right hand,
rate of descent
with a switch in his left hand.
Still very much a fly by
wire kind of automated mode.
That's actually not
so far from how pilots
fly Airbus airliners today.
He didn't turn off the computer.
He moved it to a different
level of automation
to suit what he felt was
the situation at the time.
And this was a very interesting
moment because I learned,
in the course of writing
this book, at the time,
the Soviet spacecraft were
controlled by analog computers.
And they were very
highly automated.
They left very little discretion
and role for the astronauts.
The American computer
was a general purpose
digital computer, one of the
first integrated circuits--
uses of integrated circuits.
In fact, this
computer consumed 60%
of the national output
of integrated circuits
for a couple years
during the '60s.
So it was a very advanced,
forward looking thing to do,
including all the
complexities of the software.
And yet all that
advanced technology
did not make the
machine more automated.
It just made it automated in a
more nuanced, sophisticated way
that gave the human better
control over the spacecraft.
And that gave me this
idea, which I then
pursued throughout
this new book,
that often the highest
level of automation--
we talk about levels
of automation--
is not necessarily
full autonomy.
And the most
difficult challenging
technological problem
is not full autonomy,
but rather what I've come
to call a perfect five.
If you think about level
one as fully manual,
level 10 as fully
automated, the perfect five
is really the most
complicated, difficult,
and I think also socially
and financially rewarding
place to have automated systems
where the human is in control.
There's trusted,
transparent autonomy.
And the system can be moved
up and down various levels,
turning things on,
turning things off,
in order to suit the
particular situation.
And what you see through
the Apollo story,
and many of the stories in the
book is that a lot of systems
start out in the
engineering phase
as imagining full autonomy.
The engineers on
the Apollo computer
thought there would only be
two buttons on the interface.
One would be go to moon, and
one would be take me home.
And instead of course
what you ended up
with was this very rich,
very carefully designed
mix of instruments and controls.
As these systems frequently,
time and time again,
move from laboratory
to field, there
are human interventions
and human controls
put in at critical moments.
So again, I've been talking
about the perfect five.
So the subtitle of the book
is "The Myths of Autonomy."
I want to read you a
little bit from chapter one
about what those myths are.
First there's the myth
of linear progress,
the idea that technology evolves
from direct human involvement
to remote presence, and then
to fully autonomous robots.
Political scientist
Peter Singer--
you may be familiar with
his book "Wired for War"--
epitomizes this pathology
when he writes that quote,
"this concept of keeping the
human in the loop is already
being eroded by both
policymakers and the technology
itself, which are both moving
rapidly toward pushing humans
out of the loop," unquote.
But there's no
evidence to suggest
that this is a
natural evolution,
that the technology
itself, as Singer puts it,
does any such thing.
In fact, there's good
evidence-- a lot of it
is presented in this book-- that
people are moving into deeper
intimacy with their machines.
Second is the myth
of replacement,
the idea that machines take
over human jobs one for one.
But human factors, researchers,
and cognitive systems engineers
have found that really
does automation simply
mechanize a human task.
Rather, it tends to make
the task more complex,
often increases the workload,
or at least shifts it around.
And finally, as I
mentioned, we have the myth
of full autonomy,
the Utopian idea that
robots today and in the
future should operate entirely
on their own.
Yes, automation
can certainly take
on parts of tests
that were previously
accomplished by humans.
Machines do act on
their own in response
to their environments for
certain periods of time.
But the machine that operates
entirely independently
of human direction
is a useless machine.
And I used to say that only
a rock is truly autonomous.
But then my geologist
friends reminded me
that even rocks are shaped and
formed by their environments.
Automation changes the type
of human involvement required,
transforms it, but
does not eliminate it.
For any apparently
autonomous system,
you can always find the
wrapper of human control
that makes it useful and
returns meaningful data.
The questions that
I'm interested in then
are not manned versus
unmanned, human control
versus autonomous, but
rather where are the people?
Which people are they?
What are they doing, and
when are they doing it?
And so you can trace through
networks of-- in some sense,
any programming task
is a kind of placing
of human intention,
and human design,
and human views of the world
into a piece of software that
is later executed
at some future date.
So the book covers four
extreme environments.
And the idea is that in these
extreme environments like space
flight, people have been
forced to use robotics for 30
or 40 years because,
in many cases,
it was the only way
to do a job where
people couldn't physically be.
And we can look at
those environments
and see something about
our robotic future
in more ordinary
environments like automobiles
and other aspects of daily life.
So I begin with the deep ocean
which is where my career began.
And the move from scientists
visiting the seafloor
in submarines-- you may
be familiar with Alvin,
it was a three man submarine
operated by the Oceanographic
Institute at Woods
Hole where I used
to work-- toward remote robots.
And this was the
evolution that I
was involved in starting
in the late '80s,
moving into the 1990s.
And we were all convinced
that the world was moving
from human, to
remote, to autonomous.
There was a great deal of
tension over that issue.
This image appeared in
National Geographic in 1981
in an article written by my
mentor in that field, Dr.
Robert Ballard, you may know as
the discoverer of the Titanic.
And in this article, Ballard
laid out this new vision
for exploring the seafloor which
was remote or telepresence.
And you can see there's now
a traditional oceanographic
ship-- can you see
that out there--
traditional oceanographic
ship on the surface,
a fiber optic cable,
itself a rather
new technology in the 1980s.
Then a kind of basic towed
sled called Argo in this case,
and then a little
robot called Jason
that would come off this
vehicle and explore,
in this case, the mid-ocean
ridges or hydrothermal vents.
And Ballard started
a lab at Woods Hole
called the Deep
Submergence Lab which
spent the '80s
kind of developing
this particular system.
Now interestingly, before
the Jason robot came online,
we had just the sled Argo.
And that's the thing that
actually discovered the Titanic
wreck in 1985.
In 1986 though, the
Woods Hole groups
together went back and
revisited the Titanic wreck
and sent this little
kind of proto Jason
called Jason Junior.
It connected to Alvin, the three
man submarine, little robot,
human vehicle,
remote robot, down
the grand staircase
of the Titanic,
took tremendous pictures.
It was here on the cover of the
"National Geographic" magazine.
But there was a great
deal of tension,
in some cases literally
tension pulling
on the cable between
the folks who
operated the manned
submersible, Alvin,
and the folks who felt
that remote presence was
the way of the future.
In fact, I use these two
covers because the "Geographic"
article, which
Ballard wrote, shows
only the little remote robot,
doesn't deal with Alvin at all.
And the "Time" magazine cover--
which actually, Ken Marschall
lives out here in LA, did
this painting off-- shows
only Alvin.
And this is why a lot of people
still to this day think that
Alvin discovered the
Titanic, which it didn't.
But what you see here
is a sense that actually
the human and the
robotic vehicles
are evolving together
and kind of playing off
each other in the evolution.
This image, which is a family
tree of undersea vehicles
from Woods Hole, kind
of implies by it's sort
of Darwinian ascent
nature that you
have the manned
submersible here, Alvin,
then the remote
vehicles Jason, then
this whole panoply of
autonomous vehicles.
I worked a little bit on ABE.
I talk about it in the book.
The REMUS vehicles
are the ones that
discovered the wreck
of the Air France crash
that I also discuss
in the book, moving
toward this level of
higher and higher autonomy.
But at the top of
this is vehicles
that called hybrid ROVs.
They are sometimes remote, and
they're sometimes autonomous.
And so the real
evolution is actually,
if anything, a
kind of convergence
and a blurring of the
lines between what's
a human operated vehicle,
what's a remote vehicle,
and what's an
autonomous vehicle.
These are a few different images
from some of my colleagues
at Woods Hole
about what the kind
of currently engineered future
of oceanography looks like.
Here you have what we used to
think of an autonomous vehicle.
Send it off the ship.
It'll go down like
an autonomous robot.
Run a bunch of track lines.
Keep some algorithms.
Do some mapping and come back.
But of course, as
those vehicles evolved,
they developed
acoustic technologies
to stay in touch with
what's on the ship.
And every expedition
you go on is really
a collaboration between
a manned vehicle, a ship,
and an autonomous vehicle.
And you send the robotic
system out in the morning.
It maybe comes back
a day or two later.
Exchanges energy
for information.
Talks to its human
overlords a little bit.
Goes back out, does it again.
And you have this kind of
constantly going out and coming
back.
And the autonomy is actually
pretty well bounded in time.
And there's always, again, this
kind of wrapper of, go out,
do this, come back.
Sometimes they just run
straight track lines.
But simply getting the
vehicle in six miles of water
to go out and do
something and return
is an amazing feat
of technology.
It requires all
kinds of subtlety
in the software, and algorithms,
and system design, and whatnot.
But the challenge is to
keep it under control.
I'll read you a little
passage from the book
about my experience
with the remote vehicles
and how it transformed the
presence that we experienced.
"On a summer day in 1988,
two years after the Titanic
exploration, I walked down the
stairs of an old green aluminum
building in Woods Hole
called the Deep Submergence
Laboratory.
I was there looking for a
job straight out of college,
and I was there to meet a
man named Skip Marquet, one
of the original
designers of Alvin
and the co-founder of
the Deep Submergence Lab
with Bob Ballard.
Touring around this lab, I saw
exotic robots, heavy pressure
housings, and other
things foreign to me.
'This thing's been inside the
Titanic,' Marquet said as he
pointed out Jason Junior,
opened up on a lab bench with
electronic guts spilled out.
But inside the robots
and surrounding
them were things
that were deeply
familiar to me--
electronics, microprocessors,
software manuals.
And in a moment, I was hooked.
I could bring my interests in
electronics and my engineering
degree to this unusual
alien adventure.
I was eager to travel the
world doing engineering
and build electronics
that would find
their way into
extreme environments,
and not have to report
to work in a cubicle.
I joined the Deep Submergence
Lab as a junior engineer.
What was it like then to
operate a remote robot
in the deep ocean?
First of all, we should
qualify the term robot.
The term was commonly
used for the vehicle,
but there was very little
resembling autonomy about it.
In fact, it was something
of a blank slate technically
speaking.
There was relatively little
computing power on board,
only enough to flick the lights
and instruments on and off,
turn on the thrusters, and
do some local housekeeping.
The video and most of the
instrumentation signals
went straight up
the optical fibers
and was multiplexed
through the computer
to go to the top for processing.
Even when Jason was
doing something automatic
such as holding its
own constant depth,
the feedback loops were usually
closed up on the surface
through a computer on the ship.
Jason's control room
though consisted
of five or six 27 inch video
monitors mounted on the wall,
displaying imagery from the
multiple cameras navigation
data.
A series of control
stations were
arranged beneath them, one for
the pilot, one for an engineer.
A data logger changed
the videotapes.
This left plenty
of room in the van
for a chief scientist who
usually sat behind the pilot
to direct the dive.
Then 10 or 20 other people,
other scientists, engineers,
graduate students, and
film teams from the media.
When all was stable,
the whole control van
would become concentrated
on the seafloor.
'Now that's the world of
telepresence,' the pilot Martin
Bowen said.
'That's where I
forget about my body.
And I project myself
into the ocean floor,
and have to make
that vehicle dance.'
The pilots learned to
narrow their attention
to hear just a few voices.
If the compass didn't look
right or the surface weather
was flaring up, the pilot could
ask the navigator about it.
I tended to stand
the navigation watch,
and I learned to
anticipate much of what
the pilot needed and
when he needed it--
move the ship a bit, change the
navigation quality, watch out
you're getting a little
bit close to this.
'I just started mapping things
in my own head,' Martin Bowen
said. 'What the obstacles are,
how I need to fly, how low.
I have the advantage of being
surrounded by people who are
also helping to take care.'
So our presence on the
seafloor deeply related to what
was going on that
darkened control room.
As Jason pinged and photographed
its way around shipwreck sites,
or hydrothermal vents,
or other places,
the group in the control room
was in constant conversation,
observing, questioning,
speculating on what
the cameras and sensors showed.
This constant real time seminar
about the ongoing exploration,
combined with the
beautiful haunting
images we were seeing
on the monitors,
is what transported us
into this other world.
It was the most fundamental
surprising difference
from Alvin, where even
though you were physically
near that other
world, you only had
two people plus the pilot
talking to each other."
So the rest of the book
goes through a series
of similar experiences
in other environments.
I mentioned the
undersea environment
with both remote and
autonomous vehicles.
There's a chapter
on space where I
talk about the groups who
use the Mars Exploration
rovers, not too far from here,
up at JPL, and how there, even
though they're experiencing a
20 minute time delay from when
they get their signals to when
they originated on Mars, a much
longer time delay
to issue a command
and see a response,
they still, over time,
develop an immensely
intense feeling of presence
on the red planet.
And they feel like they are
present in the landscape.
The robots up there are not
doing any geology on their own.
They're remote controlled
from the ground.
They have certain
autonomous features
that are used at certain times.
But they build a picture
on the ground, in this case
as much through large scale
paper maps as through computer
screens that the
group on the ground
can kind of explore together.
Similar stories
about the repairs
of the Hubble Space Telescope.
There were five missions
over a 15 year period
that conducted those repairs.
Beautiful choreographed
dance between humans, robots,
all networked through these
kind of extended networks.
There's a chapter on the
Predator, the remotely piloted
aircraft that the
Air Force uses both
for persistent surveillance,
real time video,
in Iraq, and Afghanistan,
and elsewhere,
and also for firing missiles
and shooting people.
And what you found there is very
similar to what we experienced
in the Jason control room.
Their bodies, the
operators of Predator
are physically removed
from the battlefield.
But their experience of warfare
is actually very, very intense,
partly because
they are doing what
aircraft pilots who are
literally above the battlefield
don't do.
The Predator pilots
will circle for hours.
They have a camera on
a single farmhouse,
or compound, or
social organization.
And because of the
social relationships
they form through the networks,
sometimes with friendly forces
on the ground who they're
trying to support,
other times of
people who they're
surveilling and potentially
attacking-- they're
still social
relationships-- gives them
a very intense
feeling of presence.
And in fact, the
Predator operators
experience post-traumatic
stress disorder
at about the same rate that the
Air Force airplane pilots do,
which is remarkable considering
they're physically not at risk.
And it's a very, very
complicated conversation--
I'm sure you've read about
in the media-- going on
within the Air Force about,
are these people warriors?
Do they deserve medals?
Do they deserve combat pay?
There's very high
rates of burnout.
It's a very kind
of unsettling-- I
hate to use this word--
but disruptive experience
for the people involved.
Similar story aboard
airliners where
I talk about how, in some
airlines, pilots are actually--
and the airlines
themselves-- are backing away
from highly automated
systems like autoland
which will land an airplane
without the pilot touching
the controls, but is a fairly
brittle, kind of high stress
situation, in favor of things
like heads up displays where
in any kind of weather,
in any kind of situation,
the pilot always does
the same procedures
and is given a flight
path vector and a guidance
cue overlaid on
the actual runway
or where the runway will be if
he can't see it for weather,
and lands that way.
Very much dependent on
software, very highly automated,
integrated technological system.
But the perception and
the motor coordination
are still going
through the human body.
And actually interestingly,
the space shuttle
had an autoland system that our
taxpayer dollars all paid for.
It was never used.
The pilots never, just like
the lunar landing pilots,
didn't like the
idea or could never
even test the autoland
system on the shuttle.
But they had the same guidance
cues and flight path vectors
in their heads up display,
which were actually
generated by the autoland.
But instead of the
autoland operating
the flight controls
directly, it sort of went
through the cognition
and the body
of the commander of
the mission and flew it
by joystick
following those cues.
So one of the things you see
is all autonomous systems--
this is actually a quote
from a DOD report in 2012.
"All autonomous systems are
joint human machine cognitive
systems.
There are no fully
autonomous systems
just as there are no fully
autonomous sailors, soldiers,
airmen, or Marines."
And you can extend that
into the civilian word world
as, there are no autonomous
pilots, drivers, other things.
Everybody's embedded
in a network.
There's always these kinds
of trades of autonomy,
particularly depending on
things like spatial positioning,
bandwidth, what kind
of networks you're in.
Those things vary over time.
So I want to read you
a more modern story
from the world of oceanography
about autonomous vehicles
to show you how this plays out.
"James Kinsey, a young
engineering scientist
at the Deep Submergence
Lab 20 years
after I started working
there, came to the job
with great plans
for the autonomy
he planned to bestow
on his vehicles.
He began to build up
probabilistic models of how
the hydrothermal vent plumes
propagate through the ocean,
and to try to instruct
the vehicles to follow
minute detections from their
sensors down to the vents.
Over time, however,
Kinsey realized
that trying to imbue that
much autonomy into the vehicle
was likely a problem
from the beginning.
Because of the nature of
oceanographic exploration,
the tasks are poorly
defined, and the environment
is always changing.
Anything programmed
into the vehicle
constituted assumptions, models
about how the world worked
that might not be
valid in a new context
where the people could see more.
'I think it focused on the
wrong aspects of autonomy
perhaps,' Kinsey told me.
'You're requiring the vehicle
to understand a lot of context
that may not be
available to it.'"
Kinsey had his own
version of the surprise
that I had talked about in a
previous chapter, experienced
by space engineers
as the abstractions
of autonomy from a kind of
design and research phase
met real applications.
"One of the problems with
having a vehicle that
makes its own decisions,
Kinsey realized, is quote,
'there's a certain amount of
opaqueness to what it's doing.
Even if you're monitoring
it, you say gee,
it just suddenly wandered
off to the southwest.
Is that a malfunction, or is it
a part of the decision tree?'
Operating in the deep
ocean is expensive,
and autonomous vehicles,
even though they're unmanned,
are far from disposable.
Kinsey observes, 'people like
to know where their stuff is,
especially when they pay
a lot of money for it.'
Overall in the ocean,
the lines between
human, remote, and autonomous
vehicles are blurring.
Engineers envision now an ocean
with many vehicles working
in concert.
Some may contain people.
Others will be
remote or autonomous.
All will be capable of shifting
modes at any given time.
Alvin recently had an upgrade.
And the new software was
actually originally designed
for autonomous vehicles.
The chain challenges are to
coordinate all these machines,
keep the humans
informed, and ensure
that the robots' actions
reflect human intentions.
Some will operate through
high bandwidth channels
like optical fibers, others
through more constrained
channels.
Some will circle close to a
node to flash up their data,
then slide back into the abyss.
Each will do as it's told
and make some decisions
on its own accord
to structures imbued
by its human programmers.
In this world undersea,
but also on land,
we can imagine autonomy as
a strangely shaped three
dimensional cloud, with
vehicles constantly
moving back and forth
across its boundaries.
Now imagine that one of
these vehicles is your car,
and the 3D cloud of autonomy
is your neighborhood.
At certain times
in certain places,
the car has some
kinds of autonomy--
stay within a highway lane or
drive in a high speed convoy.
At other times, such as if
you're far from a cell tower
or driving in snow and the ice
obscures the car's sensors,
the autonomous
capabilities are reduced,
and the driver must
be more involved.
You drive in and
out of the cloud,
delicately switching in and
out of automatic modes."
So what does this
mean for engineering?
I'm an engineer as
well as a scholar,
and I like to think
that all of this work
tells us something about how
to build autonomous systems.
One of them is this.
I've interviewed a
lot of airline pilots.
And I've asked every
single one of them,
have you ever asked
this question?
And every single one
of them says yes.
In fact, one of them
said, "oh, that's
only what the new guys
say, what's it doing now.
The experienced people say,
oh it does that sometimes."
And so I've been involved
with a partner of mine,
a company called
Aurora Flight Sciences,
building full size autonomous
vehicles for research projects.
And one of them was
this program called
AACUS, which was a full
size autonomous cargo
helicopter designed to deliver
cargo to some remote area
without putting a
human pilot at risk.
But again, there's
always a wrapper
of human activity around
any autonomous system.
And in this case,
part of that wrapper
was the people who needed
the supplies, right?
There's no reason
to go somewhere
if you don't have
something to bring someone.
And so there's a marine
landing support specialist
on the ground.
And now we were required by
ONR, this person is not a pilot,
should not have a kind of
flight control station,
and should be able to work
with the system with only
15 minutes of training.
So we talk to these folks and
we said, how would you like it
if we could build an autonomous
cargo helicopter that
has a lidar that could come
in and find a landing zone,
and land where you
want your supplies.
And they all, all of
them had experience
in Iraq and Afghanistan.
They said, oh my goodness,
no way, horrifying,
terrifying to have
a 10 ton Black Hawk
helicopter bearing down on
you at 100 knots, not fun.
They said, you have
no idea how scary it
is to be in a combat zone and
see unmanned aircraft flying
around when you don't
know who's they are,
what their intentions are,
what they're doing even.
If they're friendly
they're scary.
So we had to build
a system that had
a kind of situated
or embedded autonomy
where the people on the
ground could at least
have some basic kind of state
control of the aircraft.
The simplest one is
if it's coming in
and it actually
has a lidar on it,
you can just see some of
these operational modes here.
Here's the helicopter
scanning the terrain
and choosing a landing zone.
But maybe the landing zone
the helicopter chooses
is not one that's acceptable
to the person on the ground,
or vice versa.
So you have about a minute to
do a kind of little negotiation.
Do this, do that.
And the aircraft has to
be able to respond in ways
that the human finds
predictable, understandable.
And that basically
means relatively simple.
What we ended up with in
this case was actually
designing the kind of core
state machine for the autonomous
system-- in this case, it
was in MATLAB Stateflow--
to have these kind of
macro states of autonomy
that were very simple, very well
understood, very predictable,
and then kind of
autocoding both the user
interface and the core autonomy
mission manager out of that
to give the system a very
kind of predictable look
and feel to the person.
There's a few things they could
command the helicopter to do.
Go away, abort, circle for a
little, choose another zone.
And there were a lot
of complex algorithms
buried in each of those states.
But the states had
to be relatively
simple and straightforward.
The fly off for that
vehicle was in 2014.
It went very well.
We beat Lockheed
Martin at that game.
That program is now
progressing into other phases.
We are very proud
of our work on it.
And yet, when it was reported
in the "Wall Street Journal,"
this was the
headline-- "Navy Drones
With a Mind of Their Own."
And so there's
still a great kind
of public narrative
of, Star Wars-y,
20th century science
fiction, the drones
are coming to kill
us kinds of things,
despite the fact that
people who are closest to it
on the front lines, that's
the last thing they want.
I'll just briefly close
with another program
that we're working on.
This is a DARPA
program called ALIAS
where the assignment is really
to build a kind of robot that
sits in the co-pilot seat--
not really a robotic co-pilot
because you actually end up
changing the roles of both
the pilot and the co-pilot.
And then can either convert
an existing aircraft
into a remotely
piloted aircraft,
or can kind of
help a single pilot
and kind of-- so really,
one of the terms people
use these days is a co-robot
that allows support and help,
but still keeps the
human in the loop.
Very challenging program from
a bunch of different points
of view, but one of them that
I think is the most worthwhile
is learning how to
build a system that's
truly collaborative
and allows the pilot
to sort of go through checklists
and different procedures.
This program is written up by
John Markoff in "The New York
Times" this summer, "A Machine
in the Co-pilot's Seat."
There's a kind of prototype of
it that Aurora has already made
called Centaur, which is an
optionally piloted aircraft.
It can be flown by a human pilot
like a traditional aircraft.
It can be remotely operated
from the ground station.
Or the mode that I
think is the coolest,
you can fly the ground
station from the backseat.
And so you're like
a UAV operator,
but you're sitting in the seat.
And again, you see
this convergence
of remote, human occupied,
and autonomous vehicles.
So what can we
conclude from all this?
I'll read a little bit
from the conclusion.
"The fully autonomous
land robot making its way
through a landscape
under computer control
remains an attractive
idea for engineers.
Perceiving the environment,
classifying, matching it
up to models and
prior experience,
and making plans to move
forward resemble our daily acts
of living.
Uncertainties in the world
and within the machines,
the unexpected that will always
foil our prior assumptions
make the problem not only
harder, but even more
interesting.
Thinking these
problems through, aided
by the medium of technology
is a noble effort, engineering
at its philosophical best.
How do we observe, decide,
and act in the world?
How should we live
with uncertainty?
But we should not confuse
technical thought experiments
with what's useful
in a human context.
When lives and resources
are at stake, time and time
again, over decades of
examples given in this book,
from the deep ocean
to the outer planets,
we have reined in the autonomy.
It's not a story about
progress, that one day we'll
just advance enough
to get it right,
but a story about the move
from laboratory and R&D
into the field.
That transition
tempers the autonomy,
whether the task is to
respond to interactions
and return scientific data,
or to protect and defend
human life.
In retrospect, Neil
Armstrong's last minute manual
intervention, turning off the
automation on his moon landing,
signaled the limits of the 20th
century vision of full autonomy
and foretold the slow advent
of potent human collaboration
and presence.
The lone autonomous
drone is as much
an anachronism as the
lone unconnected computer.
The challenges of robotics
in the 20th century
are those of situating
machines within
human and social systems.
They're challenges
of relationships."
So I'll just close
with a little startup
that I've been working
on called Humatics which
aims to take what we've done
in those two projects for ONR
and DARPA and bring them to
a larger world of robotics.
How do we enable robotics
and autonomous systems
to work within
human environments?
And how do we make autonomy
transparent, trusted,
and by extension, safe
and useful for people
where other people are around?
I often say, if you look
at the full autonomy
problem in aviation, build
a fully unmanned aircraft
to take off, fly
somewhere, and land,
we solved that
problem 20 years ago.
We know how to do that.
To do that same
task from an airport
that other people are
using, through air
space that other people are
flying through, over places
where people are living,
landing at another airport
that other people
are using, we're
just beginning to think
about that problem.
That's a very
challenging problem
that we really don't
even have answers to yet.
So I'll just leave at that.
And there's a bunch
of books out there.
And we have some
time for questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So I'm really
interested in the failure modes
between, as the autonomy
is transitioning
between-- I think the Air
France example is a great one.
So you put all
these safety modes,
as we're now putting them
in cars, to prevent crashes.
And over the statistics,
they're safer.
But then you start to see these
really catastrophic failures
when but they don't work.
So how do we prevent those?
How do we keep the
pilots having context
when the autopilot
says, I need to shut off
and you're in control?
Like, it's in your lap--
DAVID MINDELL: Great question.
Obviously, really
essential issue.
I've talked a lot about
the Air France crash
because it's sort of the
classic hand off tragedy.
First of all, you can
look into that story
and you can see that there are
things that the airliner could
have been programmed to do to
make the transition smoother.
For example, it lost its air
data from the pitot tubes
when they iced over.
And at that point,
just checked out,
said, OK, no more
fly by wire at all.
You're in a manual
reversion mode.
Here you go.
Right?
Again, if you think about
engineering the relationship--
which wasn't really done when
that airliner was designed--
you can think about a
lot of alternatives.
Anybody who programs
flight controls for UAVs
will tell you that you
could fly perfectly flying
without pitot tubes, right?
You have a sort of basic
internal flight model.
You knew you were going
at a certain rate.
It's perfectly
capable of holding
the airplane stable for
a while, quite a while
actually, or descending
to a safe altitude
while the crew can sort of--
Secondly, the
interfaces on airliners
are really not all that well
designed by modern standards.
And they are designed to
kind of shift liability
as much as they are to
provide insight into what's
going on inside the system.
Thirdly, and this
has come up quite
a bit since that crash and a
couple other crashes as well,
the pilot's manual skills
had clearly degraded.
I mean, flying an airliner
at a very high altitude,
often autopilot, is
not an easy task.
The air is very thin.
The line between
stalling and overspeeding
is a very narrow line.
It's not something
that's typically done.
At the same time, every
beginner pilot is taught,
when the airplane is stalling,
don't pull the stick back.
And in the Air France case,
one guy pulled it back
and one guy pushed it forward.
So the hand off is challenging.
There are a lot of places
that it's done well.
There are other places
that it's done poorly.
There's certainly room
for innovation there.
In fact, I think, again,
if we see the perfect five
as a goal of the
technology, then
we should focus on improving
the hand offs in lots
of different directions.
One of the goals of the book
is to at least point out
places that it's happened
in these other cases that
are useful examples for
people who are working
and other technologies today.
So absolutely essential thing.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So it's not
a huge tactical leap
to go from the
assisted helicopter,
for instance, landing at the
human supervision to adding
forward looking
infrared and a minigun
to start blasting
anything with heat.
Are there things
that can be done
to prevent that, or
prevent the evil genius,
or the little subshot
of CIA from developing
these technologies that
really, technically, aren't
that difficult after these
other problems are solved?
DAVID MINDELL: Right,
that's a great question too.
The current US military official
policy is we don't do that.
Weapons are always
released under some kind
of human approval process.
And I think, if
anything, I would almost
guess that that policy will
become stronger because there's
a fear among general
military professionals
like, what do we actually do?
If actually joysticking
the aircraft maybe
isn't our great skill
anymore, and we're
getting kind of pushed
around in the networks, well,
deciding who to kill and when,
that's an important thing.
That said, there's a long
history of autonomy in weapons.
And a guided missile
from the 1950s
is, again, a kind of situated
autonomy where a human aims
a device and releases it.
And it has some sort
of automatic function.
And the debates are
really about what
is an appropriate and acceptable
line for those things.
Landmines are autonomous
vehicles, right?
And they're autonomous
weapons without a lot
of discrimination.
And a lot of people feel they're
beyond an ethical line that's
acceptable.
So some of these issues have a
long rooting in other questions
about weapons.
I personally feel you're a
lot more likely to get killed
by a poorly designed
robot then you are
to get killed by an evil robot.
And that kind of poor
design and poor situating
is really a much more
immediate concern
for us, a la Air
France or other things,
than the evil robots
coming to take over.
AUDIENCE: I think this may be
a little bit of a follow up
on the Air France,
except on the ground.
There's a lot of work
and a lot of press
lately about the development
of these autonomous vehicles,
the self driving cars.
And I was wondering if you have
any comments or ideas of how
you think that's
going to go, or how
you think it should develop.
DAVID MINDELL: Yeah,
great question.
And I do discuss
this in the book.
I believe that we should
be able to improve
the safety of automobiles,
and even radically change
the driver experience using
all the good stuff that you've
read about-- machine
vision, and lidars,
other kinds of advanced
sensors, path planning.
But I think it
should be organized
around keeping the human deeply
involved in the experience.
Reducing workload, yes.
Allowing you to text, yes.
Allowing relief of
boring activities
like sitting in traffic
jams, by all means.
Sleeping in the trunk, no.
And sleeping in the trunk with
your kids in the backseat,
again, there are
30 or 40 examples
about how that's
really not a safe way
to think about a system.
It's a very interesting, very
important debate as you know.
In the last week, since
the book came out,
Tesla released one of its
early autopilot features,
and a lot of people
feel released it
without the proper--
beta testing
is not something you
really do with your users
when they're going down the
highway at 90 miles an hour.
It's very different from
software in other realms.
And there are some
interesting stuff popping up
about various ways that there
are problems potentially
with that algorithm.
I think that particular
issue has more
to do with software
testing and release policy
than it does with
what's the right way
to automate the vehicle.
But it's still very
much on people's minds.
And I know there are people
in the driverless car
community who are horrified.
I think they're
right that if there's
an accident in the
next week or two
with this early release
of this software,
it will set back a lot of
people's idea of progress
for a long time.
That said, I think it's
amazing and exciting to think
about, how can we use
technology and driving to expand
your experience of the
world, and bring you more
richly out into the environment
that you're in, whether it's
your situatedness vis
a vis other people,
or the geographic environment,
or other parts of the driving
task, while at the same time
relieving you of-- I'm a pilot
and I fly long
distances in my plane.
But I can mostly do it like
this where my hands are crossed
and I'm looking.
And things don't
change all that fast
unless there's a small
number of emergencies.
Whereas when I drive,
I'm, you know, got
my shoulders tensed up.
And a car or a hit could run our
in front of you at any moment.
That's a much more kind
of tense experience.
I think there's any
every reason to believe
we can relieve that kind
of hyperactive nervousness
of driving into things that
will both reduce error, reduce
fatigue, reduce workload.
But again, I have a lot
of trouble imagining
sleeping in the
back of the trunk
while the car is barrelling
down the highway.
AUDIENCE: Also,
I'm wondering is,
is there likely a
human factors part?
Because one of the issues with
some of the autopilots when
they kick out is that
the highly trained pilots
have trouble figuring out how
to move into the mode of flying.
And is that going
to be a problem
particularly with drivers?
DAVID MINDELL: You get
manual skill degradation
if you don't practice it enough.
And that's something
to certainly consider.
Although again, when you're
going in a fly by wire world,
the manual skills are things
that you can kind of construct,
technically.
There's nothing
that says that this
has to be how you drive a car.
People have been trying
these things for decades.
But two joysticks down near
your waist as a possible way
you can drive the car.
That's actually how they
flew the lunar module.
And interfaces need
to be designed well.
There's always challenges
with human factors issues.
The regulatory environment
is challenging.
But it's very hard to picture
a fully autonomous car
that doesn't have a red
stop button, or at least
some kind of intervention.
And if you think about
what that constitutes,
it constitutes the saying
that the driving task
has been understood completely,
in some prior space and time,
by other people.
And there's no possibility that
you being in the environment
at the particular time have
nothing to add to the story.
That's just something we know is
not true, because being there,
and being the most immediate
person, and the one
with your rear end on the line,
provides you with information
that the system
may benefit from.
And so there are
other ways to think
about how you might do that.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So if I was half my age
and entering college,
what field of study
should I go into if I'm
interested in robotics
and this field?
Is it more software these
days, or is there still
a lot of hardware,
or a combination?
DAVID MINDELL: That's
a great question.
Obviously the software is
critical, and exciting,
and interesting.
And at the same time,
all of these problems
actually point to
improvements in sensors
that are needed that
you might not even
see if you weren't thinking
about them in this way.
That's one of the
things Humanics
is going to do is build new
kinds of sensors that enable
autonomous systems
to work in closer
proximity to human environments.
I'm an electrical engineer.
I like building embedded
systems and I do some of both.
But I do think that the
hardware innovation is
equally interesting to
the software innovation.
I think on just the autonomous
car side, as much at Google
as anywhere else, there's been
amazing improvement in lidar
and bringing the cost down,
simply because of the needs
that driving has presented.
And lidar has limits.
So there are other systems that
are going to come out as well.
I don't know that it breaks
down either hardware or software
per se.
I do think that all of those
innovations kind of need
to be coupled with these higher
level system configurations.
And one of the things that
was really important to me
in that AACUS helicopter program
was that what I'm talking about
is not just an interface issue.
Yes, we need better interfaces.
Yes we need good interfaces.
But no amount of good
interface is going on
put a Band-Aid on a system
that behaves unpredictably
or in ways that people
can't relate to.
It's really about how
you design the system
and kind of conceptualize
the core autonomy.
AUDIENCE: So you were talking
about the self-piloting cars
and how you would never be
comfortable without having
a big red stop
button in your car.
And that would be very nice.
I like that button.
But what I really want is that
button in everybody else's car.
DAVID MINDELL:
That you can stop?
AUDIENCE: That I can stop.
So if a car comes barreling
down the road with some crazy
driver, and I cannot react in
a way that will save me inside
of my vehicle, for
that vehicle to stop.
That's really my greater
fear when I drive around
Los Angeles is not the software
or even my own reactions,
but just the crazy things
that sometimes happen.
DAVID MINDELL: Yep, that's
certainly true anyway.
AUDIENCE: In a
way, all the time.
DAVID MINDELL: No
matter what car
you make, with no
matter what technology,
at some level you're
only going to eliminate
half the accidents,
which are the ones where
you run into other people.
A lot of accidents are people
running into things, actually.
AUDIENCE: Well like,
you can't stop the wall.
DAVID MINDELL: Well another
way to say it is you
can build a car that
won't hit anything.
And if you build a car
that won't hit anything,
that doesn't mean it needs
to be fully autonomous.
It can sort of do
collision avoidance
or collision prevention.
Those are probably never
going to be perfect.
My Volvo right now
will slam on the brakes
if I rear end someone.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
But my question is, one thing
the technology can really do
is it has these
communication protocols that
are much faster than the
ways humans can communicate.
So there is a way, using
software, using robots,
to make the driving experience
in this case considerably
safer by ensuring other
people won't hit you.
And that's something
that I think--
I'm sorry to interrupt you--
is something that is really
absent from this discussion
right now of all this exercise
safety potential of
autonomous decision making.
So how do you think we can
change that conversation?
DAVID MINDELL: Well I
think that's a great point.
And again, I think you have
to think about the autonomy as
situated in a human setting.
That means other cars, other
drivers with their pluses
and minuses as
operators, and thinking
about those relationships,
whether it's
V to V communications, or radar
sensors, or ultrasonic sensors,
or whatever, are all things
that you do need to think about.
I doubt we'll achieve
perfection in any of them.
But I think there's some
low handing fruit probably
that can be addressed.
So by all means.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVID MINDELL: Might
you like to know
if the person who's
behind you on the highway
has a history of drunk
driving convictions?
Yeah, I would like to know that.
But there are privacy
and equity issues
around that kind of thing.
AUDIENCE: So I have a
quick question that's
related to the hand off issue.
It seems like to make the
hand off, whether it's planned
or emergency safe,
you're going to have
to build up some kind of model
of whether to believe and trust
the user, the actual
human input or not, which
stress as problematic.
Like in a self
driving car situation,
if something strange
happens, hand off occurs.
User is maybe not
paying attention
and does something like slam
on the break in an unsafe way
or swerve in an unsafe
way, at a certain point
the machine is going to have to
decide, no, I don't trust you.
Is that problematic?
DAVID MINDELL: It is actually.
It's an old question.
They asked this question
about the Apollo computer.
They asked it about
an Airbus airliner.
Should the computer
allow the person
to do something dangerous?
It's a great question,
really interesting one.
AUDIENCE: And presuming
that you know the difference
between dangerous and not--
DAVID MINDELL: Well exactly.
I mean, that's a human judgment.
All you're really
saying in that case
is that I'm shifting
the judgment of what's
dangerous from the
person in the environment
to a group of people
sitting around the table
six months before.
And there's good
reasons to do that.
People sitting around the table
are probably not fatigued.
They have a lot more
time to deliberate.
There's collectively more brain
power, so on and so forth.
And at the same time, the
person who's in there, however
drunk, or tired, or
silly they may be,
are seeing things that you
couldn't see otherwise.
That's just a judgment call
really that needs to be made,
that is being made every
time a parameter is set,
a threshold is set,
a configuration
file-- I actually have
a story in the book
about the configuration
file for one
of the DARPA Grand
Challenge cars, which
is a source of a lot of--
it was 1,300 lines long.
There were 1,300 parameters
that people had to go in
and manually set to
make that thing work.
I'm curious what the
modern cars are for that.
And that's fine.
And obviously you try to
eliminate them and make
them more automated.
But there's still a lot
of tweaking and setting
that goes on inside of any
kind of AI system these days.
And those judgments
should be transparent
and understood who's making
them, why, for what reason.
That gets as simple as, when
you drive to the grocery store,
do you want to prioritize
speed of travel,
fuel efficiency, or safety?
Very often those
three things are
in conflict with each other.
Somebody's got to
make that decision.
I'm just saying it might as
well be you rather than somebody
behind closed doors.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have question regarded
the perfect five scenario.
Will this be applicable
20 years down the line,
or is just in the veil for
incremental development
to autonomy?
DAVID MINDELL: Applicable to?
AUDIENCE: 20 years
down the line,
will perfect five
would still be your--
DAVID MINDELL: Yeah, I do
actually don't think-- I mean,
again all the evidence you've
seen in the last 50 years
is that systems that get
deployed where there are lives
at stake end up in that state.
So it's an empirical argument
based on many, many systems
studies, basically.
I could be wrong in 20 years.
I mean, if had told
someone in 1960
that they could make a computer
with a 10 megahertz clock rate
and all of three
megabytes of RAM,
they would have said
of course, that'll
be plenty to get us
fully autonomous ships.
And indeed that
happened, and computers
have done all kinds
of amazing things,
but there are still
human interventions
in all of these systems.
So I could be proven wrong.
But it is an empirical
argument based
on how people have done this
for many previous decades.
AUDIENCE: But incrementally,
wouldn't human intervention
would be like, we would
kind of forget the basics.
Like, I came to
US two years back,
and now I can't drive stick.
So incrementally, even all these
things start getting added.
Now all of these
semi-autonomous cars are here,
and then I might just
forget the very basics
of having that intervention.
DAVID MINDELL: And again,
these things all go on.
And ditto with the
anti-lock brakes.
I'm sure none of you
ever have to stop on ice,
but from where I come from, we
all brake on ice all the time.
And you have to change the
way that you use the brakes
actually when you have that.
There are all these
little forms of autonomy
that come up from the ground up.
But I would argue they're still
sort of managed by the user.
And in fact, your car still
has a low gear one and low gear
two.
I don't know if all cars have
that, but most cars have that.
And so you have
the automatic mode.
And then for whatever
reasons, again, it's
no, sometimes there are reasons.
You can go into those low gears.
So you're still have a gear
shift in the car, interestingly
enough.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVID MINDELL: Great.
Thanks for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]